back again a single cup is a finally
finally over so I'm just going to show
up and play a few games of blitz at
least for now on let's see who wants to
play challenge a couple the top guys
alright on the plates got Jackie see
what do you want to do all right let's
see four nine three three play once a
grünfeld go just to complete this should
be three when you to probably take takes
all right 96 play Roxy one takes takes
probably castles something along these
lines
um yes Abbot's are just asked is this
live yeah I should be live right now as
far as I can tell I could be wrong huh
the night is still young
but yeah that was er I am actually
online right now so play hmm don't
believe it rips e4 to e6 I'll play King
you to please Knight a5 I've kind of
bungled this a little bit already but
played Bishop d3 if a six maybe Bishop
g5 maybe work c5 um okay I really kind
of messed this up a little bit but
whatever time to play is there nothing
has happened the dish about for if takes
and I've got Bishop c7
uhh
so yeah all right you guys all right
guys just making sure that I'm live
since I just saw in the chat someone
said um someone asked if this was live
or not so um so all right okay so he
just took the took the pawn on d5 I'll
play differences sobbing a bishop aged
six probably kini too as I said before
this kind of hasn't gone exactly
according to plan
um okay trip d7 now this really hasn't
gone according to plan okay I'll play
there should be 596 probably 95 the move
um let's see what I want to do here so I
take he'll take e4 okay I'll just play
e5 I'm going to try and swindle him I
completely massive sobs it's not how
you're supposed to play this at all so
go play nice okay Bishop d6 or takes
takes Bishop d6 probably take 95 or d6
king c3 not ideal but it's still again
the takes takes and c3 probably Bishop
e6 clear p16 this pawn here on b7 first
and I'll play rip d1 f64 so it's a good
move
I'll play King before give them a shot
it's I'm kind of meeting that maybe ok
c3 I'll play rook c1 c8 yeah this is not
going to be good so I'm going to try and
swindle home let's just see what I can
come up with here bishop a - rookie 7c -
um yeah this is not a good start to the
evening
this guy's got work b3 that was not a
good start let me get set up here
alright see what I can do here clicky
697 flick something a little bit silly
27 I played d5 okay tonight c5 Knight f8
like I'll display night c5 here night
off hit ran into cleanup 3 probably so
let's see what he wants to do
Bishop C to play h6 here probably just
simplest just kick the night away than
just castle probably Knight f3 castles
Bishop f4 I think let's play this
leadership c6 off for an exchange who is
this guy by the way Chuckie 2015 closes
in a second so he doesn't he doesn't
disclose his name okay so I'm just ask
is this the hippo yeah this is some kind
of version of the hippo I mean it's not
not precisely the hippo but it's
something something fairly close to the
hippo so there should be three I'll
point 96 of Queen d5 is Queen d7
therefore I want to be really funny I
can also play King d7 but Queen d7 seems
like the correct way to play this now I
can play g5 not play g5 all moves are
possible here but yeah I think I'll just
go g5 905 and castles probably probably
will try to attack me or with a 45
possibly but a 4 I can always just play
a 5 I think I will play a 5 or b1 I'm
going to be a little bit careful here so
if I play nicely sized here what does he
have here it should be sick so the play
95 and he takes I can just take the D
pawn yeah let's just see okay
so what's he going to do so take I'll
take with the D pawn 97 I'll just take
play King b7 maybe or I'll just take the
knight
okay rook d1 Queen e8 allows Knight East
7 probably so I have work 88 maybe just
to hold everything then it's got night
h6 let's see so what is the best way to
play this
so you does not have an actual threader
he does he does kindness not really
clear what it's actual threat is but all
this liver cage seven cover the c7
square protect upon in h6 and now I
might be threatening Queenie ain't next
move also
so probably going to have to take on d7
maybe I'll take and probably play 97 if
you want to take on e5 I'll just take
tonight on f5 so takes I'll play rook d3
or detail play rook d2 and go for work
82 probably important that I keep my
king close to this close here to the
center on alright now I'll play rook C
to try and try and take take advantage
of these squares here okay so now I play
broke up three and now I'm going to play
rook a to IV five will play rugby seven
I'm just going to try to gob walls pawns
if I can this is H for the cake probably
he'll take
I've got all these cons here on the on
the Queen side which should count for
something
this is decisions many things draw is
not one of them feel a little bit
careful here I think I can take the
Frick f-18 v7 if we request seven I can
clear Ricky eight f7 I think I feel
broke up for torching c6 also for King
pig 53 Kings 16 b7 f5 ok so I can play
workout forks of takes I go king c6 King
be 7 to 7 and now it's time to roll up
on 14 3 6 and B 5 B 4 is coming next
move
I've also got a big time advantage here
as well so I'm going to go B 5 B 4 B 3
as fast as I can here King b5 probably C
5 C 4 also is coming I do it to be a
little bit careful here but this is a
funny out game we're all like all pawns
are coming on board that was a dad and
the ladies a lot of 7 but this still
should be winning takes rook e1 c3 g6 c
2 looks like I'm winning by tempo okay
so I'll get back to playing random chest
this time C we want to do see what's
everyone's saying said someone won a
tournament in a in a website in Riga in
Latvia so interesting I didn't hear
about the term that's certainly
interesting to note I wasn't implying
his week I was simply stating that he's
not what I consider as a super strong
player at the moment I mean I say it's
hard to tell because I think he played
the
the place Andrew tank played the hosted
the US Junior Championship I think it
was painted reasonably well on but he
didn't do anything special so I kind of
was uh so I don't really know a whole
lot about him so 94
I think I will take and play three four
tonight back then maybe H 3 F 3 he can
also play a six here
so with c6 all this plate there should
be three tags and castles I send home
plate work e8 or have lit cleaning five
which is a little bit where else we be
four okay so he wants okay so wants just
exchange Queens and play something
rather boring so so be it Castle fish
would be three I'll flavor key one team
loses Bishop probably just 93 on the
obverse 183 on fish and betrayal play
rook you won
- six help us to record now I'll bring
my knight back to f1 and probably e3 in
a second so what's up with everyone
wearing ridiculous shirts is that a
comment to me or is that a general
comment a little bit confused I don't
know I don't know who that comments
direct towards I'm sorry if my shirt
facility that's not my intention
caolan80 - probably he'll take on b4 I
soon and I'll take back with the C pawn
d4 is protected by the bishop so Oh
presumably LaVon under sub LaVon could
be LaVon I mean he's had the style for a
while then it's not really anything new
so it shouldn't really come as a
surprise to anyone I'm wondering what he
wears okay I'll play Bishop I'll play
I'll play a four try to go for a 45
maybe 97 also as a Thank You 7 c5 yeah
this makes sense
rook e8 maybe I'll play 95 or maybe I'll
just play a 5a Knight b6 probably want
to do something over here on the king's
head so I put the bishop here to protect
this pawn ok so now I definitely is
trying so what I'm trying to gain time
on a clock here do some random moves
maybe a little bit on see what he wants
maybe a 6 if you take I'll take on c6
and get some some kind of play if he
takes I don't know if they'll take on a
six dozen this allow a7 or am i insane
it's a seven-night p6 game over
dirty degenerate just said knocking you
look good on TV thanks for that you know
another life I'll consider being a TV
anchor I guess guess a d4 Knight of 64
I'll play some right I'll keep sticking
to the theme of playing random stuff
there should be 7.2 to e6e for and I've
gotten myself into a bad version of the
nihms oh because I'm just that good
okay c5 d5 I feel like this is some
known line here with b5 I can't I don't
remember exactly how it goes because
normally I don't play this but I know
line is considered to be bad for black
so but let's see what Jackie is going to
do here you could take on e6 maybe take
out any six take on taking out b5 s
probably backside just take d5 on maybe
b3 is a little bit weird maybe you can
keep the whole pawn structure together
but I think we'll just have to wait and
see what he does some bull time
someone's just a slot episode six of
Game of Thrones I'm thinking of quitting
G ot completely completely the writing
has been awful and I'm about to quit
quit the show forever yeah I mean it's
is I saw episode six last night too I
mean I have to say I wasn't wasn't
thrilled by it but it certainly
certainly is I mean it's not not which
we would expect I think I mean I think
at least according to the books which I
haven't read actually I mean aren't I
feel like John and Daenerys aren't they
supposed to be like chooses on or
something I think if I remember
correctly so I mean again I haven't read
the book so that's what I've heard from
multiple people and now they're
apparently like together or something I
mean I'm not going to spoil it for those
of you who haven't actually seen episode
6 yet but probably not not the not the
best episode ever but there-there was
there were a couple very good plot
twists in that episode
then this guy meanwhile his trap has
work on b7 with this Bishop here I'm
just starting in Queen CA maybe
in the meantime if you take I'll just
take back so Queen a for so queen c8
hopefully Queen sees sex I guess I can
play E for first so I play efore o go
Bishop c2 Queen c6 so I'll just play
this the point being that if I played on
e4 Bishop see to that here after Queen
c6 and I if you please clean c6 which I
assume he will once I take and play rook
88 the bishops here if I'd played efore
he would have Bishop a4 because the
bishops hearing the Pont aeri doesn't so
I'll take 95 probably probably maybe not
I placed 94 um now also 98 try to trap
this rook again maybe with 96 obviously
these seven here but maybe I can get an
f5 to again f5 now it's starting to look
really nice because it's 93 you can go
could play work d6 maybe it's one option
yeah I think I will play work do so it's
just exchange set of rook so this these
pawns are good and this rook here is so
active there's just a good idea so all
right I'll play king of 795 King e6 he
wants to exchange clever ah he does want
to exchange okay so I'll take play he
for prohibition so forth and the seven
that's probably draw he king of
something was a bad move I have to say
so so you want to do play g6 kind of
miss played this a little bit okay but
now I got rook e8 at least now there's
some hope player okey 7ft not for I'll
play King c8 maybe 46 okay he wants to
play this okay I'll have to flack and
now it's annoying
I played off for real okay interest in
probably works c6 hopefully work d7 try
to track him or t14 you through okay for
very hard to win this it should just be
a draw objectively but I'm going to try
and flag and about five I can play g5
goes clover k3 try to gain some time if
I take a six takes out 77 that was a
good move our gauge so excite and see
that okay so if I take use Bishop c6 oh
okay
I'm going to try and push this icon it's
going to be hard to win this
yeah probably just a draw unfortunately
oh he doesn't want to draw okay
I mean he could have just taken a draw
but now I got the flag on inside well
that was a eventful on to say the least
um okay so okay play Englisher probably
d5 no okay
fish b7o what to do I'll play g3 give
them d5 if you want to just play some
kind of Sicilian here probably takes the
compute to maybe 93 maybe not
can I be so close play d4 takes 90 so
play d5 castles tripped you for h3 um
doesn't this trap a bit different geez
looks out for ah his Bishop c5 King H
294 I call your bluff
so you take I just take they move the
knight to d3 I just play off five so
this looks pretty good
nachus class skills make mere mortals
envious
thanks for the compliment Caston Orkin
alright so takes clean aged Forbush page
three this is pretty desperate for block
maybe h5 Queen e1 so he plays f5 I
completely g5 but I think I'll just keep
it really simple here and play just
cleaning one try to exchange pieces
since I am to stop a piece here Queenie
someone's play Knight g3 offer another
Queen exchange if he doesn't take but
now it's pawn here is hanging so this
should be pretty routine now just a
matter of technique Evan
there's
kind of hard to not not win this but you
never know I could I could blunder it's
not impossible takes takes takes have d6
elves play obviously we're okay he's
starting work f2 is any fine I let's
play work f1 take the open off file for
us and you're chocking on h4 or play
Roxy for all political c1 bishop c2 I
could plead e6 here but I would what's
what's the point just 95 simple simple
moves non-threatening 96 potentially on
in fact 96 is a threat now I can't take
the back rank on f8 so let's see all
right let's see any any other comments
um let's see oh did he just resign he
did just resign okay alright let's let's
go again okay I'll keep playing some
rather offbeat stuff on say okay I'll
sufficient p4 is six probably castles
okay Queen you to d5 probably five or
not
I'll take okay castle taken for Queen h5
I'll just take my 97 this is pretty draw
to actually it's like Bishop b5 exchange
but White has CC pawns which are not
ideal now he plays a4 which is an
interesting mode I'm going to take and
play I play Knight e4 see what he has
all his ideas here please - Webster I'm
just going to castle enough a 5 just
Knight c3 is hanging since I'm
protecting the bishop I mean his pawn
structure here is pretty awful I mean
letting letting these pawns become like
this on on a c2 c3 845 is not not great
to place a 5 now I can take a pawn and I
think I will all just all just grab upon
mr. d5 Bishop g5 I do not see
I'll play Rocky 8c one spring the fish
are back to e for cover this a square
and now I can do many things I can play
Bishop d5 for example which I think I
will just just take away the C formula
but now I'm just going to play king b7
and R okay so he's trying to create
counter play here but I do have to
connect at a sponsor which I mean maybe
I'll maybe I won't play this precisely
but it feels like the pawns should be
winning so I'm going to play where cafe
try to force him to take to seven
because now I figure that if once rooks
come off these these two pawns would be
really good 6 e 515 c 6g 405 Bishop d5
trying to do something against these
pawns
C 423 I was like ok 8 for it so he's
trying to launch his pond
now again I've kind of made a little bit
of a mess out of this rather
unnecessarily I think hopefully we're
okay for 5 takes b4 probably 6b 3 again
we're ending up in some kind of crazy
pond race which feels terribly
unnecessary terribly unnecessary but
okay Bishop f6 for flavor K to the e7
I'd fish about 7 or no I don't because
then he is rook takes c4 oops
King bee 7 or D 1 not not ideal not
ideal to bishops III also rip g8 6 fish
about 7 not perfect it's not perfect but
now he blundered rook g3 Chuck I think
and once a missing something is king
before there's rook d3 cleaned each
other's work d3 also so I'm King before
I'll take ok another one like b3 Bishop
e2
there's about five Knight f3 I'm a flat
earther and I'm going to be inside
during Chiclets
ah it's a good comment um
no weak chest that is not me I'm not a
flat earther I'm not a knock Kyrie so I
know you're trying to be funny but I
definitely definitely believe in certain
other things in fact I think my second
he's going to a Nebraska or Kansas and
he's going to go see the Eclipse himself
so yeah that's that's definitely not oh
not not what I am or kh6 he's trying to
do some kind of made over here play us
through I can play Knight f4 also for
that matter but I think I'll just I
don't know what I'll do I'll just play
off three because Queen h4 I can just
say h3 I think and then if you takes on
e5 I can take on e4 I'm sorry this isn't
making sense all you guys I'm just
thinking thinking aloud to myself so he
takes so ok so now if I take with the
pawn I'm attacking the fish from the
night so you wants me to take so you can
take King h1 or h2 mate but I don't have
to actually allow that I think I can
play let's play Bishop d4 I can play
Queen d3 maybe even bishop see one looks
interesting
ok Queen c1 Queen h4 h 393 takes takes
takes rook h3 Queen c5 looks good ok
this is messy though ok so if I play
something is there anything else Bishop
d4 takes 84 Queen H cleaning schwöre is
not actually a maid thread is it
so I flick Queen to on Queen h4 and I
take taking f2
yeah I don't see it so I'm just going to
play Bishop b4 i can play Knight d4 here
which I think I will
so he plays cleaning for so I take and
play cleaning shoot King off - it's
unclear I'm just going to play h3 even
though I don't I don't know if it's
necessary
um just to see what he wants to do here
is h5 night h3 maybe that could be a
slight problem I'll take I'll just see
what he wants to do if you if you want
to actually take or not probably he will
take I assume but I'm not sure so ah he
is the other order or wait no live King
h1 not on yeah eh one Oakley make sure
to clean a shoe Burke g3 I've worked out
- I think I think you misplace it
supposedly clean extra Queens you two
done work G so it's not not Chuck first
um so uh alright so let's see what I
mean maybe see 596 I think he just see
confuses order so if you go back a few
moves he definitely better than this up
for employee for here I can also just
take but maybe if I take e63 Knight f5
wreckage this looks good
takes Knight f5 looks looks pretty
awesome probably he'll take I would
assume or okay server cage to tonight a
5-4 gauge to probably queen h5 this guy
is tricky I will give them that
so I have moves here what am I playing
work Chi one maybe no no work she ones
about it then he just takes okay so I've
got to figure this one out so if I go 97
it's good snitch eight
oh we played King f8 now I can just
chuck him and now I just lose this he
was supposed to go key nature and that
was very unclear um I just no I just
down a ton of material I'll just take
and take the Chuck Jake they were like
work to 5e - king - - and now it's
running checkmate over here on each one
so d4 I'll play v6 more of the same
probably 597 or havlin IPD - honestly
push b7 these 597 c5 c3 put my queen c8
dish basic idea try to exchange all the
exchange pieces go into some kind of
deep long endgame here
it plays Queen do you wanna play h6
probably nine to three three six just to
make sure nothing happens here and not
on play 96 and I'll probably Castle long
I can also play c4 though since we play
to a3
now I can't open the Queen side over
here
well Castle I mean he might try anyway
with b4 which I kind of suspected 9594
wants to play this way this probably is
an ideal because with this pawn
structure uses backward pawn on c3 and I
also maybe have 94 - I don't know if I
want to do it is there any way to attack
this pawn on e6 not really solids play
rook c8 or not ethics as pawn b5 sorry
so I'll just play what will I play here
maybe Bishop g5 f4 I'll just play 98 and
he seems to be holding here so I'm just
gonna have to play some normal moves now
okay to drive 93 here I think I do in a
fork b2 I can just take 95 King c6 these
got work DD - I'll play h5 just - if I
take take on v5p as Knight a5 so I'm
just going to try and keep some pressure
alive
with like just play normal moves over
here make sure this isn't a weakness
bring the work to c8 I don't see a
threat again so this play work c8 see
what you want to do here clicking off
one I can always take I'm just going to
go back to a make and move this night
away from v3 here now I'll play Knight
d7 probably work B 394 something like
this oh I'll take whatever play works c7
t1 play f6 or if I want to I think I
will now I'll try to make it interesting
play h4 98 98 I really want to get this
Knight to d6 and see for now it's only
something I'm looking very good again
this looks really good for black the h3
try to fix these pawns over here on the
King side probably f4 g4 and now his
Knights pretty bad rolls to my knight
so let's play what will I play here I'll
play Knight f5 not that night of 5 has a
point probably just a bad move play 94
and c2 I'll play works d4 93 rook c8
it's still not trivial actually to play
this a place can be too I can take on c3
9594 night before what is the night
before just take on b5 now that's not
going to get it done all right so no you
guys actually I'm not holding my
microphone tonight actually I got a
stand so I know how the sound is you
guys if there's there any issues with
the sound oh let me know and I'll try to
take care of it in 85 to take probably
would be 566 rook a 5 is a move I'll
play King B 6 probably work a1 all I'll
take or K 6 probably and I'll play not
King C 5 I would be battle taking C 7
probably he'll take if you take C 6 I
broke be a to cut the King off force
them all the way over to the a file so
let's see so I'll play
what will I play here I can play rook 6
6 I'm just going to play d3 though King
a4 I'll play rook B - I mean I'm
threatening to take each - I don't know
if I want to but I'll just do it I'll
just play a rook F 2 X 2 4 D 2 F 7 um
I'll just take and player got 3 and at
aah -
if your gauge 5 row gauge 3 takes yeah
this is just lost so alright okay Brooke
up phone tune 3 3 now that's just kind
of over okay efore I'll play 94 pushup
c5 interesting um what to do I think
we'll play d4 takes if this would be 492
I think all go this way 92 here I should
be 404 bishops III takes takes
and I mean this kind of is not what I
was trying to do this is exactly not
what I was trying to do played Bishop a4
and III b4 I mean it's kind of us maybe
okay I don't know if this is okay or not
I feel like somehow it's gone wrong here
like this is not how is it supposed to
go so let's play Queen d2 b5 I'll take
numbers gonna have to bluff now blow up
and try to make it work with the pawns
not really ideal like b4 try to make him
take on c4 I guess he has rook be a
tricky one first but he's still gonna
have to take on c4 I think or not maybe
not okay so it plays 48 I can play b5
takes takes Queen e7 it's not going to
work
complete four that's not going to work
either
hoho what to do okay I'll just take and
I'll play I'll just cast I'll just play
cause 93 Queen b6 92 or cleaning seven
on display 92 if 95 or b3 I still do
have two pawns here for the piece so
it's not I mean it's losing objectively
but it's not as bad as it could be I
think it's the way I would put it
kevrah C 8 I'll play a four again if you
want the sack on d3 that's by all means
he can but he doesn't so I'll play I'll
play b5 I'm going to go a 94 next move
on he can play d4 here but I'll just
take the knight okay so nine to force it
takes takes h5 l to h3 just no Knight g4
s I'm gonna play rook somewhere now I'll
just play off for f5 f6 maybe 97 Queen F
to try to pick up this age for pawn
clean up 6 I'll go back to d2 and play
rock c1 next move
96 this is not good I'll just take clay
Knight f3 try to pick up this age for
pawn as always on again I keep
forgetting that he can just play d4 yeah
that's not going to get it done if I
play f5 no 95 this is pretty ugly
efore takes Knight before I'll try e4
all up I'll try somehow to make this
work 93 Knight f5 but I mean this
doesn't look very good
ok please rip d8 let's run a check
sauron another shock I'll take put b6 I
mean this is obviously just lost but you
never know maybe I can maybe I can get a
lucky swindle son somehow okay big ticks
I'm in king q to Knight c4 um could be
7-6 play 46 Center 3 takes takes
can you forcing us sexy Hauser's is
awesome stuff to wait six come out to
the others I mean there's no point
playing this oh no this is stupid just
blundered a piece for no reason in the
opening so you want to do look at the
feed three I'll play h6v 497 let's get
any comments 92 I'll play 96
2492 h v 9 h 5
yeah so 92 h 5 I'm gonna go h 4f for all
mostly 5 and let the bad move it is
night of 5 okay thank you 7 King update
fish about 14 to 7 night of 5 fe 3 I see
you guys want me to play someone else I
guess um Andrew tang maybe if he thought
what I didn't see if who's on line right
now no oh he is on line okay oh my might
claim a few games let me see if I can
beat this guy like let's see I'll try
and beat this guy six in a row I'm gonna
try to beat him six in a row that's my
goal 96 I'll take these five I'll play
King g7 if you take on f4 I can just
take and take on in five
does he ever chief for some weird stuff
here probably solve this take on e5
and if you go into g3 I think I can just
play queen g5 here if 94 I take take
Queen e3 Chuck I'm threatening Queen III
here actually it takes take the king or
the Queen I'm taking what the Queen
seems more sensible good de5 but now now
I h4 woke up four is his idea so I'll
just play work d8 make sure you can't
move at night anywhere Queen eight for
now I can go H for H three if I want to
well yeah why not let's just see what he
has here about four I'll play h3
probably hold the g3 probably no he's
going to go clean takes a seven so you
so I take what the pawn his work up to
and if I take with the bishop he has
rook up to also I guess so let's say
okay so I think I'm going to take with
the pawn and play 95 takes in work D -
it seems like a reasonable plan if he
takes I take the night because the night
the night is protecting the rug and I
have a queen here so so if you take the
night I can take on d2 and if he doesn't
take the night I've rook e8 trapping the
Queen so ten second challenge no I've
never actually done a ton second
challenge you played rook you want to
network HS trout's the Queen okay that's
that's one of that's one of six let's
try not not get a bishop trapped on the
edge in this game I won so this guy
wants to like Fabiano Fabiano style 492
5c 493 sickles take pic play Bishop c4
explains cleaning a5 I think I go d5
actually I think you might have just
missed played this all all together
I mean d-5 looks really inviting I don't
know if it's the best move I could
always just casually go yeah why not
just castle picture d7 this is really
really he's really inviting me here to
do something I guess I'll just leave
work see once we can't castle cannot
explain it before okay I'm just going to
play d5 I don't know if it works but it
looks like a logical move now I'm going
to play can play a3 I can play Queen h5
also I'm going to play Queen h5 is clean
g6 though I forgot about Queen G sex
that's a slight issue um now I'll
probably take on d5 but it's still 95 a
94 maybe 94 Knight f4 very strange I'll
try it
so Knight f4 okay I can trade Queens I
can also wait no I can't I can play
Knight G 3 also right yeah I think I can
so I'm gonna play Knight e3
ninety-three of course is not non-normal
move X I just spotted that it worked on
Mike antique yeah I'm just going to take
like King out seven I've got rook c7
plays work c8 which is weird um so I
maybe I just take and play work see one
anywhere and I don't really understand
what he's doing here but let's just say
okay which would be seven now I'll just
take I wouldn't normally take the knife
here I kind of want to UM my 58 I'll
just take out five he moves the King
I'll take out five Chuck
she takes I'll just take I mean I think
he might just resign here but we'll see
38 cell does take a 93 no back rent
maids here play like split off for take
liji for play h4 basically use all these
kinks use the kingside majority here c6
like play up 5 obviously g5x Trixie 6 3
can you 7 f5 and this should just be
lost
hang on so 8 think night of 5g 786 makes
the most sense
ok so he plays a 3 here so I mean I
think work c7 just is meetings I've got
g7 an ith 6 here basically I'm just
starting q7 ith 6 to 17 e8 rookie Rookie
7 is checkmate
so let's just see what let's just see
what he wants to do here not sure but
let's let's see
so you please work the 8th or work 8
sorry
I can play d6 or not d6 sorry just go g7
Keaney 8 I think f7 yeah f7 takes 96 is
just winning and I just I check made him
buy one move here with GA
so that's too close okay so hopefully
six play just a normal normal opening
here
d5 pigs cakes fish about 405 c5 play
like d4 see what he wants to do I guess
you can just Castle here yeah that
wasn't very smart play knight c6 3 I'll
just take I don't know this is a let's
play normal pretend pretend nothing has
happened just uh I guess he has Castle
blonde here hasn't he so he's Casablanca
can I take advantage of that I guess ok
lah psycho all given this and play
cleanup for tracking like Bishop f5 it's
going to got quite dangerous actually
because now if King b1 I go Bishop a5
Bishop d3 night before I don't know it
looks pretty good done the camera down a
bit a bit more okay there we go I don't
know is that better
you guys tell me is that better
and uh okay so that's better
okay all right there's b3 I'll play
Knight before maybe as Queen d2 what am
I missing can I just take the knight
take the bishop here clean out forge
fish before okay that was weird
okay so that's three oh he says good
game Thanks
way to kill the stream man way to kill
the stream that's not cool
all right I'll challenge on this jazz
Martinez I guess he looks like a next
highest rated guy
I guess we'll play penguin I'll play
pound when I'll play pound when a few
games since that's what some of you guys
want to see at least um so let's see
okay penguin play something so you six
so what everyone wants to play Queen c2
suddenly this guy is he's just watching
my stream or something
all right so this this seems this is a
very slow game I have to say it and I'm
play knight c6 try to exchange on t4
because who takes so now I play d4 it's
different than the last game so um oh I
don't know what do I want to do here I
guess I have to figure out what I want
to do first
hopefully choose five an official g3
I'll play 94 maybe he'll take I don't
know he could take a guess but it seems
kind of weird so he plays Bishop to e3
please Bond cloud the penguin okay I'll
see what I can do about that
um he's what efore I think he plays d4
d5 so I'll at least consider I don't
know if I can make it work but all I'll
think about it
okay there should be three I can take on
c3 and take on c5 that looks kind of
weird um in play Bishop a5 I guess and
then this looks a little bit weird like
I feel like I've done something wrong
here but it's still a game probably I
mean castles queen up six let's just see
what he wants to do earth d1 all I can
take maybe takes leadership g4 something
like us Queen d5 disrupt three maybe or
Queen d5 work 88 so position not so
clear
if he takes probably all flavor da is
what I think I'll do but let's let's see
what he wants to do first so all right
okay so he's really thinking here see
what you want to do
okay sure these are quite a bit of time
though are my lagging it's probably
using time so Queen takes d5 all up
labor kd8 Queenie for I'll just take
Queen f3 Queen c3h for logical move on
and take on d1 I can play King g7 I
think I'll just play King g7 here let
them let them take on g5 and play like
Queen f6 probably
click clean op 6 and play f4 maybe f-14
g6 or this page 4 but that doesn't
create an actual threat so play King h6
I guess I think I will force him back to
Bishop g3 and then go like kinky sex
the idea being I want to let Queen out 5
here so if I play something ok so it
plays rook a B 1 I can take and play
rook d8 probably i think AI why not just
takes oh he takes the Queen aha
clever okay I'll play rook no this play
B sucks simple choice c1 play like King
juice 7 maybe 25 97 I didn't play this
well but he's also kind of mess played
this too so it's not not so trivial for
either side now his bishop is okay but
he love me let me put my night on much
better square that I should have been
allowed to put it on so the game
continues its Queen b6 I will I don't
really want to take maybe up to Queen B
to try and try and do something here
crying complicate matters at the very
least maybe hope play like work d1 then
I'll play like rook c8 take the file
see we want to do here because he's kind
of miss played just a little bit I mean
this is this isn't quite week but I
think he was hoping for so Queen d7 I'll
play Queen B for F 323 425 lat
Alton 87 probably Bishop Bishop f2 it
okay it's also 95 obviously C wants to
do what am I going
ah there we go
and pick up the bishops and that was not
good best game I've ever played on but
it'll do I guess okay so c5 III I have
three probably Bishop g4 Bishop f5 906
ok p4l take 94
I think kind of went wrong very slightly
misplayed this
it's Queen if five what does clean a
five do let's play c3 unless you want to
sleep ish cakes b1 here maybe he wants
yeah you want to take okay so now I
think I'll play like well I think I'll
play b4 maybe it takes Bishop b5 looks
pretty good umm actually looks quite
strong so it takes no wait chat takes if
I take take Queen d2 that's no good so I
can take on B 196 Queen b3
that looks pretty good actually so yeah
I'm just going to take and play like
Queen b3
I mean maybe he'll take on c5 maybe
that's his thought do you take on c5 I
probably have Nightbeat 3
so we'll see what he wants to do here
so tonight to circulate Queen b3 if you
take I'll take maybe not maybe actually
take on d4 teak b7 to attack the rook
okay so Queen c7 off with Bishop eight
three putting more pressure on b7 no
place 94 I think you can just take here
and just take something look very good
actually this looks pretty bad
so
who's my favorite player to play over
the board there are a few people I don't
mind playing down to think like who is
there there's I mean obviously Magnus
loves I mean I wants to have any one
particularly there's no one in
particular that I think I would prefer
to play I mean it's joyful playing guess
everyone so it's that I don't think
there's anyone who is a specialist Ari I
forgot cool comdev says bond cloud
waiting room right I forgot about that
all I'll work it in here I'll work it in
here unfortunately I don't think I can
really make it work with black so let's
see what I can do here I please fish
before I thought Andrew normally tried
to play very heavy theory for the most
part white and black I mean I listen to
recall that that he very rarely plays
it's like london system type of stuff so
night 83 that looks very suspicious if i
take these what he wants to go 94 but
can't I take on beat V to 95 this looks
wrong somehow
I mean think for a second it seems very
wrong so I take on b2 he's going to play
an IP 596 review on clean a choose at
raw or is it work I want young so if I
take 95 CD for 97 King DA takes Bishop
before 92 or can you to somehow
sometime not sure about this so I'm just
going to take on d4 if you please 94
maybe I'll check on b4 maybe I'll check
them before I'm not sure yet place 95
even stranger on now I can play d6 maybe
and at least Queen B for what just takes
94 yeah I think I'll just play d6 plays
Queen before all does take takes
probably will take with the pawn I'll
put like King d7 oh I probably let him
off the hook here I feel like somehow
what he did was not right but doesn't
seem like I I haven't really played this
correctly so we'll see what he wants to
do
um Sarah wants to see me play play dr.
Tancredi let later has docked incredi
been around ivan actually seen him
recently him or her i guess they could
be it could be female after all since I
character is a female I believe so if
it's easy for a play King d7 I mean I
might have a problem here something like
95 but maybe not maybe just 95 I mean
what we'll see it anyway ok so he played
c4 I'll just put like there should be
seven and knight c6 I guess although I
did just allow c5 which could be a huge
problem guess you didn't see it so I'll
just play knight c6 and now I think I
should be fine if I play this correctly
on complete b6 maybe or a 6b 6b 6d v
looks like an issue so I think I'm just
going to kick the knight first now maybe
is there a way to kick the bishop now if
I'll just play d5 95 just Keeney 8
probably if you take I'll just take
obviously take the I'll just take with a
knight
he is being awfully slow in this game um
how much did your Rolex cost I think
it's one known as that was it was a gift
so I did not did not buy it but the
retail is pretty the retail price for
that watches is pretty insane I have to
admit so work hu1 so I've got to figure
out how to on how to extricate my King
here I think work d8 Keaney a king si it
makes the most sense I don't know if
it's I mean feels like they're problems
here but but maybe not mate but okay if
he's going to play it like this and I
can just take and play like this ee 6
it's looking very nice assuming there's
no tactic that wins immediately which I
complete this v6 I think I'll display
work a7 just so Knight b6 doesn't hit
anything and bitten there's no Bishop c7
I don't feel like King f8 that might
have been a bad move that might have a
lot there should be aid but whatever
it's not the end of the world probably
um so if I tell you can play rook d7
Bishop B this is kind of ugly
but again it does not look to me like
I'm just lost here so I'm gonna just try
to hang on somehow it's like Bishop
Bishop h5 Bishop g6 try to try to
exchange the pieces at least get this
rough sides as to what Philippa should
be 7 okay I don't understand 97 I go
King g8 okay so please fish page 3
that's really weird looks like King GA
can be to leave it off 8k play 98
probably 96 next move and maybe 95 if I
get a chance or
yeah f5 was a bad move if I was really
bad no I'm just going to basically
flagging or something Stu but at the
free pawn that's a free chalk that's a
free shot to chuck isn't it just me or
not
oh no it's not me whoops how many it's a
long time how do I get so long time as I
just - how do I get so long time
knocking I thought it was up on time and
then somehow you know time that was
really weird but alright some of them is
cruising and then suddenly I something I
had like 10 seconds which it's very
shrink so I thought it was just like
moving normally okay 93 takes I'll take
a queen
probably dish up see six maybe or just
Knight g4 Queen d2 a 500-point 85
efficiency six el primer kc-10 51 put
each 500 ch3 no 94 nonsense okay now it
sounds like it's time to go after him so
I'll play a four queen bee four or five
six maybe f5 also g4 here which hobby is
rookie for boy that was not not so smart
I somehow forgot about rookie for rookie
for Queen c3 maybe it's still okay
though actually strangely enough so and
King g8 I've fished about three probably
I mean ever by putting his pawns on each
five shi-jiiy success 7 he's kind of put
them selling a little bit of trouble
here on the King side so this would wish
boss three Queens 7 on flicking off -
maybe GG 5 is now serious threat so
please a foros would be 4 could play a 3
here I guess bad bishops donated $10
thank you Bob bishops appreciate the
donation I'll try and try and keep on
winning for you okay so be fixed g5
chess was a donation from chest I think
it was so alright
so keeping with the game 294 I'm going
to take now I can take you plays Queen
off 5.06 that looks pretty good yeah I
think that looks good so so he plays
clean out 5 I'll play Queen f6 and now
he's going to have to take because now
with the pawns here on these squares
like with the structure the way it can
never attack was pawn up six and you
can't attack this pawn on f6 I mean he's
going to exchange obviously he can't
ever attack the pawns no no to a3 know
it so now he can never never attack this
pawn on b4 so all my pawns are really
really well placed now so
I mean it's just practically resign able
actually so the adults play age for
nothing no I'm going to do over here and
I'll put real c6 take and I can justly
45 and pontius March up the board so he
should probably resign here on FDA for
okay next one point nine oh six B six
okay I'll just play I'll just play
traditional now LC
all right I guess dr. ascetic but what
those that a host that's hosting yeah
okay all right 95 will play g6g 400
mighty moves all right I can play Knight
g7 a guy I don't know that's the right
move but it looks interesting fee on
keto ni night behind us pause it please
each four-foot h5
let's see what we want to do here so
let's just see all right so it takes so
now I don't have to take I can also take
this knife yarny five first I think it
makes sense to just get rid of this
night it's probably take Sandro page
five and maybe visualg five then see
what he's going to do knocking we're
doing it one taller alright thanks for
that thanks for the donation on to
Nakamura
thanks for add that I inspire you so
much that you are using the same name
okay so here he's going to play Bishop
g5 obviously all maybe we'll play Queen
c7 maybe not I don't really like my
pieces that much here I might even just
sack my clean just because I think so
why not let's just push have some fun
because here as pawns are very advanced
and so therefore like I get if I get to
just like develop and put a knight on f5
and castle I should be doing relatively
okay here slots I'm doing great by any
means but with these ponds so far
advanced on I should be doing okay here
so I don't know I don't really want to
trade but I'll just do it I'll play
Knight a5 and now it's the L player okay
Jay probably takes takes four point
ninety seven Queen three b6 just want to
put my night here on g6 please see for
all chuckin probably be three Bishop c6
King c2 now I can't eat I can play were
caged to also think I want to play were
caged to queen g1 flavor gauge for
and already this is getting a little bit
messy now because again the way the
structure is these pawns are not not
great for white here so take I can take
the night about allows g6 so I'll just
take with the Bishop Queen three on
their moneymaker I can play 96 I guess I
don't know what's wrong knight c6
actually and queen c3 I'll play like I
have to be careful here
clicking V 794 now I can just take maybe
not just think like Rick a four or
something
play rook d4 because the cleaning it I
can just grab this pawn on e5
I mean probably it's still a draw if you
please cleaning it but I'm not sure he's
going to first of all okay so he did so
yeah so this should just be a draw now
but maybe I can still trick them let's
see you can i let's see if i can hang on
to spot this f-pawn here
now I'm going to try to meet them over
here somehow
whoops and that's what we call it fork
um all right let's see okay I'll put b3
which would be to play another another
one of these Larsen's against Larson
systems oh I forgot I'm Swiss play the
ball and cloud or someone that's right I
forgot that I need to remember that so
I'll do that next game all right so I
planted penguin guys it takes e4 e5
interesting okay now take
maybe takes me a bit should be five
maybe plays Bishop before probably just
bishops III just see what else who wants
to do here so he takes with the night so
he wants leave it should be four so
let's play a three stop this Chuck and
then I'm just going to play Bishop d3 or
c4 Knox move so there should be seven
will play which would be three and I'm
just going to castle maybe work d8 maybe
castles probably all play Queen c2
regardless okay and I guess residents
leave just donated donated money so
thanks for the donation residents Lee
glad you're enjoying the stream I have
three attack upon here on e5 probably
Bishop f6 or f6 let's also move but now
now this pawn structure is not not so
great in fact Wow h6 Wow all kinds of
awesome squares along with long diagonal
now and this just very very nice so
okay so it plays rook da um maybe I just
chuck him my play 96 takes don't I just
want an exchange here with Knight Fe and
isn't there just a fork on c7 and d8 or
am I just crazy
Queen b7 I'll take B for a 5 that was
rather stupid but whatever I'll play e4
kick the night away probably night-night
a4g 396 Queen C floor maybe she'll play
King to 295 I'll just check probably
play h4 h4 just kick this night so no
nonsense over here now take but I think
I'll just play rock f d1 I realize I
just did give him if takes I've clean up
7 Queenie Fortson g1 and I'm just up a
piece if you play something else I don't
know no I don't actually live in Saint
Louis I've been here for for a couple of
weeks for the sinkhole caught it on the
rapid and blitz portion of this as well
so I do not actually live in st. Louis
but I've been here for quite a while now
to answer the question Bishop e7 played
Bishop e3 threatened or k7 it's now
Fischer protects a square so it's
running work a7 maybe he'll take on d4
maybe not okay he tasted the bishops in
our case 7 yeah it should be the game so
let's see what's d4 Knight f6 c-46 n c3
some more more on nimzo-indian stuffs a
thrill okay
play more standard stuff maybe I'll play
h4 likes far-off did today I got
something but I guess not not today and
I'll play some size probably they'll
take on f6 is going to take on take on
c5 so not work c8 so let's see what's
going to be work d1 I think the right
move here is on the Queenie 7 Urkel and
I think I do believe it's Queenie Czaban
so I'll see
so sort of asking me if he came back
we'd be top five I don't know if he
could be top five it's hard to tell I
think it's very hard especially this
most most of the players myself included
we tended to UM fish we tended to avoid
going into preparation on in most of the
games where where we try to just play
slide line so you got a lot of fart we
got a lot of very good positions and I'm
not really sure if you would get those
same positions if we were playing main
line theory it's it's very hard to tell
I think the main thing was nobody nobody
really tried to play theoretical against
him and so therefore it's a little bit
hard to judge the good positions he got
versus on verse you know what would
happen you know and almost slow of that
but nevertheless he he did play quite
well so III I'll take played work c5
probably moves the Queen d2 e4 somewhere
for cleaning for 0.92 6b 400 there d5
ooh that's not good
okay Fleur work d5 probably he'll take I
don't know maybe if he plays rook these
five times like when you know I can't
play Queen at one so if he takes I just
take
so let's see um alright what's he going
to do maybe it'll just I don't know
maybe he's not even maybe you're just
going to like kini to or something I
don't actually know finding out how
penguin tends to be extremely fast when
we play bullet but it please float when
we play like blitz he tends to move very
slowly very deliberately which is just
interesting to note because more often
than not people who are very good at
bullet don't seem to be maybe not able
but they don't they don't seem to move
much slower when I play blitz plays a
little woods so please work c1 I can
play Queen B - I think Brooks c6 Clara
no work Queen B - work c6 Queen and 191
is just gg so I play work ad 8 work c6
5191 Queen h1 can you two not um not
clean okay so I don't really want to
move my knight but I don't see anything
better to do so I'm just going to move
it not I mean I still probably am very
slightly better although here you can
play g3 probably I need to see the
scaping somehow we please clean c2 s now
I'm going to go work d8 King - so right
there should be something here but I
don't see it right off but I'm still
going to try and be very glad Sona plate
g5 play g4 Nighy one I'm going to take
and play 95 c1 like a queen e5 maybe try
to attack Assad's down here
thank you try hard for donating a dollar
to my stream I appreciate it glad you're
enjoying the stream so far okay it's a
queen e4 now in a play like how do we
capitalize right not saying I'd s excuse
cleanup for so it's queen c6 what is
queen c6
that is cake so you just wants to try
and play classical now just gambit upon
and try to just continue playing so
Queen c7 call just take and play like a
five I'll just pay you can play like 94
it's probably just losing now I mean I
can just take and put like track night
at 593 is coming too and it's just this
is pretty ugly for block or for white I
should say and that should be too much
so
alright let's see so okay so this would
be to be three out of three can play
Bishop a5 Bishop g4 or something okay so
II six so now I'll play Bishop d3 this
would be six I'll take Castle 64 be six
of a three to play d4 I will
okay complain is c3
Queenie seven I'll play Queen c2 maybe
f5 or h6 I mean both news are playable
play Roxy one perk FDA I'll play
I think I'll throw on this shock track
and Bishop b4 probably Rexy a queen with
two maybe
a five I think all this retreat right
try and play along the super long down
with these pawns here on e6 f5 can be
king g8 I'll play like Bush p2 again
trying to play on this long diagonal I
don't know what I'm doing I'm going to
repeat moves and see what you want to do
now I'll play like Liberty one so it's
trying to basically keep on defending
here somehow
I'm not really sure what the goal is so
I can play b5 here and I think I think I
will actually I'll just go for it now so
it takes high place 95 right away I
don't take on d8 and then I'll play
there should be five I don't know it
looks interesting he's put his knight on
the rim here so I think it makes him
sons to play like this now 95 oh he's
got he's got checkmate in one okay so
now I do need to be a little bit careful
closely h3 if he takes I'll take I mean
his ninth here on e5 so bad relative to
my bishop that seems relatively okay so
you please e5 play this would be one
probably queen g6 or queen acetic not
for which square is going to goes to f6
now I think I can play off for if you
take so I just take and I take on Volvo
pH to play work g1 probably Queen off
six here I would assume
now clean off seven okay so I'll take
play fish p6 p7 on flavor 2/6 right and
checkmate in one on h6
and I'll just take a pond now
and I want to go Queenie five I get the
chance like in a move or two so let's
just see what he wants to do I'm going
to have enough $1 to buy anything I want
in a vending machine
that would be true but unfortunately we
are in the u.s. we're not in Japan so I
mean there aren't like vending machines
on every corner out here so it would be
a little bit hard to just buy stuff from
the vending machine other than other
than pop obviously what you can just you
know you can get anywhere
okay so 42 king g3 I should be winning
with these two - passed pawns hearing
that there are extremely strong 94 ELLs
playoff for not sure it's the best move
but it makes some sense
I mean these these pawns are how I have
to be hard to win the game because if I
can get these pawns rolling the Bishop
Bishop should dominate the night
so okay - I'll play rook c6 probably
work a three King up to king h4 maybe as
a move also I'm not crazy about it
93 or the bishop g6 now it's running
mate 1 and now I am really threatening
mate and one is rook e8 so let's see
okay so alright
so we want to do so this might just be a
repeat of that previous game
thank you $1 and I think we know you
donated ha ha so keep it coming keep it
coming you guys so it's okay so probably
hopefully like bit of g5 again I assume
I mean we have this we have this
position oh I feel like we have this a
few games ago
I'll put Queen c7 this time play
something a little bit different try and
mix it up a bit
see what he wants to do so let's just
see
um
okay so he's thinking quite hard here
maybe I felt like penguin doesn't
normally play as he feels like I feel
like he's the guy who plays like the
super classical like stuff all the time
so I'm surprised to see this tonight of
six Bishop before Bishop d6 probably he
can play up for also not that I I don't
really expect it but it's a move I'm
going to play h5 just to make it
interesting I'm cheap I maybe I'll buy
you for FY not see what happens if he
takes takes Queens before of about a
five opening this long diagonal and this
looks quite nice um again his pawns are
quite he really likes to push his pawn
to g5 but it's like it's getting him
into trouble because he's ending up in
these pawn structures where he's like up
a pawn but he has this huge hole on f5
that he can't really cover like did
someone donate I didn't see that
unfortunately advise so anyway
continuing on I'm gonna play Bishop d6
97 9 or 5 is my plan probably he'll play
push page 3 I would assume maybe not I
mean this is really kind of ugly this is
why you don't I mean white has this
extra palm the square on f5 is so good
for blocks night
so see you
okay so let's see okay so this page
three I'll take play Knight f5 on say
Knight f1 plea b5 here I guess try and
open it up I think I will just to make
it interesting I can't take on any three
because then he takes and he's got
Knight d5 here so Bishop g2 before maybe
maybe yeah well let's just see
probably he'll play 93 here probably but
I'm not I'm not sure so he takes very
interesting interesting decision to take
on b4 so now I have to figure out what I
want to do so I am play Queen b6 is
there any way I can do something here
that's non-standard maybe like Queen d7
I like Queen d7 just trying to put
pressure on this work on h3 force it to
move and then play Queen e6 here and
again you can't play 93 could be four is
hangouts threatening to play e turn
myself okay so he castles I'll Chuck and
I will play King Gustav and I'm just
going to play normal moves here just
just try and play chocen create
something so I take on d4 now he's got
bishop c3 so that kind of wasn't very
good okay I'll play work e8 yeah I
really must played this a little bit now
so I'm gonna have to work hard so I'll
take fish we trail take on b4 h5 I can
take I don't have to I I will take
though clicking g4 so BL sorry BL beat
bgh 13 just donated Thank You BBJ age 13
it's real play rook h3 to Bishop d6
cuff one I can play something here go
play wiki 8 and now if f 5l play work F
3 but you saw it so ok 73 or 58 okay
that's not the best move
so it has g6 memory but then I can take
III probably if I take take tape g7 we
should be fishing okay I'll just take
and now I've got a choice I think all
this take there's a four oh shoot that
was terrible
oh that was very unfortunate no that was
just awful
okay now I've got to be passing on the
side
so let's see if I can somehow whoops
there goes a rock
alright you guys so I'm going to play
him one more I think and then I'm going
to stop knots off tonight but I'm gonna
stop playing against himself
alright for like he need to for you guys
one times Vaughn cloud let's see if I
can make it work but he played a six
normally and replace the French I think
that most of time this is bad obviously
for white but I feel like most of the
time if you can against the French this
is not terrible it's not great but it's
not there are worse sites like II 45 is
a lot worse than this so so this e 7
I'll play how do I play or I'll just
play off 4 F 4 E 5 makes sense
in fact e 597 d 4 maybe it's actually
looking quite decent now to f6 will
tonight of 3fc I play FV this actually
looks surprisingly reasonable much much
more reasonable than it should
ni PD 294 I can take if I want to I
think I should probably try not to take
new just like play Knight beat 3 s's
King has a big problem obviously so I'm
gonna have to navigate some of those
issues I think I'm just kidding I'm just
going to gambit a pawn over here on the
Queen side just to get some stability
here on the Kings side and so now I'm
gonna play this page 3 try to put some
pressure on this pawn queen e8 he wants
to go to g6 I don't like Queen B 1 try
and cut off the square and now maybe
I've got something on tv5 with h7 to
this would be seven now I'm going to how
am I going to run I think I'm just going
to run King up to team two - it just
just ignore everything
I'll give them Queen a - if you want it
on in fact now I'm going to play Knight
e5 though no six eight eight takes I'm
getting a knight I'm getting a knight to
d4 now e6 is going to be weak so let's
see let's see what he wants to do okay
so b4 I'm going to play 94 rook e8 I'll
play c6
I mean this has gotten very messy from
position that should have just been like
very good for for black okay so you're
going to sack is that his intention I
don't know
please bishop CA then I'm just going to
go over okay one
so he plays 93 now I can take if I
wanted to with the night I don't know if
I want to but there any good reason not
to
I don't see it so I'm going to go for it
Thank You Simon he'll take obviously
probably work CA now I'll play e6
threaten e7 now it's actually very very
tricky
you can play Knight d5 maybe but I also
have to pass pawn so we both can play to
pass pawns here so it's not simple Kings
crusher thanks for the donation just saw
it across the screen I would would say
more about it but this is a ton scam I'm
trying to win the bonds I'll keep my
perfect record intact so I don't think
I've ever lost with the long pod before
so alright sometimes laugh out loud or
laugh LMFAO
yeah it's LMFAO that donation okay so
you please d-force now east 7 is a move
east 7 I'm just going to Queen what is
he doing again I'm very confused
someone's going in too deep think then
he's playing some kind of strange moves
I'm not understanding now but I just got
Ricky one now I checked and obviously
Ricky eight and it's just over
it's very strange very strange alright
let's see who else is on line Chucky is
still here does he want to play or not
I'm not sure
I don't know if he wants to play so all
right and in the meantime you guys I
will will any any questions on let's see
ok ok I guess no one's around I'll just
keep playing penguin I mean no reason
not to
so let's let's keep going on
so all right Knight f3 all bubbly be
striving different there should be seven
which would be five I'll page six
h4 plays d6 probably III and IV to seven
just playing chess or Bishop e7 I could
take on f3 I am in but I don't really
feel like it close play Knight 9:57 III
Bishop e7 Bishop d3 well I'll just play
chief 5c wants to and I guess maybe I
you just have g4 hair even I think you
kind of miss played this a little bit
he's gotten himself into some serious
trouble out of nowhere
night h4 night h5 looks really really
good so let's see let's see what he
wants to do 92 I don't have to take but
I will this which would be 7 probably
castles I'll play h5
just to see what you want to do here can
be one play h4 I guess I could play h4 I
don't really like age for no let's play
a 600 I'll wait and see what how he
wants to proceed here because he is down
the pond in a3 I can play c5 I'm just
very skeptical about whether it's good
okay I'll just play e5 I'll make him up
to decide right away Knight d4 and if I
play h4 her I play h4 here what am I
missing
h4 d takes e5 94 age for Knight f6
Bishop f6 I'm not getting it I'm not
understanding what he's doing I could be
missing a very obvious tactic here that
would not be surprising okay so please D
so I take he takes so I take on g3 he
takes f6 yeah I don't see any reason not
to oh wait oh wait wait if I take he
takes on e7 oops that was a mistake
oops oops oops big mistake hmm now let's
turn to something normal it's very very
unfortunate hmm
all right now I just have to play this
like normal games
now that's frustrating but it's still
still positions fine game goes on
positions roughly equal here
so takes probably queenie forking b8 the
bond cloud opening by hikari aqua New
York Times best seller 100% win rate
that would be pretty funny Rick before
I've night of three
yeah a night of three workout for not
crazy so I'll just play work age to try
to force workout for I don't really want
to maybe take a draw here but Matt Hall
clingy six please ninety-four
interesting does not want to play normal
moves and make a draw so I can play
Knight f3 play rook e8 maybe rook e8
looks looks like a good move here from
d1 now maybe Knight f3 why not
I'm hoping that I'm not overlooking some
very obvious tactic here because I'm
putting my pieces on very strange
squares so I literally five thank you
shy shy turtle boy thanks for the
donation
come on Andrew your times ticking you
got to move you got to move man
a4 okay I was wondering about this 95
move to lose and I'm wondering you more
about it I don't see a reason why I
shouldn't be fine
so riff D 496 now I'd huh
what Oh takes work up seven wait what
we're got 17 GA for King a maybe I'm
confused
is he just out of material that was
charged all right let's see what's is uh
improvement
I will donate $150 it so improves P
equals MT 30 seconds ago is in PP equals
MT is there's not one of those 1 million
dollar math problems that no one is
solved or am I completely insane I
thought that was one of those math
problems that note that no one had
solved and someone can clarify that for
me h6 let's see what do I want to do
here h5 is a possible move c4 c4 e6 c5
women don't really understand what's
going on in this game but we'll see soon
so now a circle take probably 95 I'm
guessing I mean this is all very very
weird honestly I want to play Knight c3
place east six I'm gonna play there
should be five if there's before I just
take on c6 I'm I win by one tempo
I also probably throwing eh5 at some
point I haven't yet decided one please
rook c8 now I'm gonna throw in each
fraud now now I can take on c6 and take
on d5 I can also just Castle I think
I'll just Castle here and uh okay so
what else done it who farted a bunch
okay fair enough
there's Castle let's see let's see what
he wants to do
this is Queen g5 what let's clean you
five Kantor you feel like f4 or
something here somehow all of all of
Andrews moves are really confusing I'm
not not expecting for like any of the
new cities playing right now there so I
don't know that's a good thing or bad
thing
it's going to be like Queen g3 or Queen
Queen d8 maybe 93 but it's all kind of a
little bit scary here for for block so
okay so who are the most promising under
18 chess players in your opinion naka um
I don't know I actually haven't been
following the Junior junior ranks that
closely I mean obviously there's way Eve
but he's he's over 18 um oops
wait did I just blunder again it looks
like bad blunder very very bad blunder
um who queen due to night of one you
know I don't know if this works but I'm
just going to play it because I want to
UM I mean this probably doesn't work but
it's okay but now even Itay for and now
it's only he's gone I mean I don't
normally like to sack queens for just
one piece because it should be losing
all the time but sometimes this is this
one's going to work out really really
nicely and just like a perfect clean
fack poor Andrew though man I mean
that's got to be rough th one I've been
H is completely busted here there's
nothing you can really do so let's see
okay
there should be four not three castles
d5 takes
see five probably he'll take I assume I
don't know 8750 - I can play g5 here I
guess I'm going to reason not to
probably this is not how it's supposed
to play this on letting ins wish get to
e5 but I've been playing for quite a
while and I'm starting to get a little
bit tired so down to make some mistakes
now now and then he takes I'll take that
all probably take that with the night
probably don't have to but it makes
sense Queen c2 Queen d5 doesn't move
I mean I'm slightly worse here but
probably it's not the end of the world
Andrew I'm I'm not poor ha ha ha ha
that's a good one uh I like that that's
a good one bye poor I didn't mean
financially but thank you for the
donation Andrew
so h3 place c5 maybe 92 or 95 but I
think I'll play c5 just take away the
square from the night more importantly
so he's know 94 it should be for now the
pawns quite good here also celebrity
size
King you to I'll probably play out five
I think um and makes most sons please g4
that's a good move
I could play off for I guess and I
really don't like it but it seems like a
move why not see for now I can play 92
that's option one I don't see an option
to unfortunately it's like and I didn't
really want to play this because now
he's going to be able to exchange rooks
but that's how it goes sometimes and
plays rook a4 actually which is I wasn't
expecting okay I can play Knight f4
night if for Knight h3 and make a draw
play 94 and not make a draw I I left not
to make a draw like this position should
be a draw but I mean I've won so many
games I don't really feel like making a
draw here so I'm just going to try to
swindle him somehow
see if I can make it work
maybe play like night before something I
don't know what I'm doing exactly but
I'm gonna try and trick them somehow
stuff like this or Chuck 93 I mean I'm
getting them making some progress now
some kind of progress I don't know what
kind of progress but something take 95
work c7v 5 will play like hooking up 7
I'll just play a 5 night before now I
got to be careful about 96 coming to
whoa
kingi 6 I've gotten myself into some
trouble now but he's got no open files
that's the important thing he doesn't
have a B file or enough fire on anything
like that plays a 97 I think I can just
go a for this worked before I think I'm
just going to chuck it click Heaney 7
can be 5 I'll check him over k play CH
okay I've got to really start working
some magic now to try and win this new
Knight c3 but can be sector so now he's
trying to
yeah I'm gonna have to make a draw here
unfortunately but he can't exchange if
you exchange he loses the on game oh and
now I've 9800 Wow Wow
and as I said before just just to prove
that it's a winning endgame on okay poor
Andrew I'm gonna say it again poor
Andrew and when I say poor I don't mean
uh I don't mean financially all right
d43 then we're going up in something
cree similar to what we had in those
previous cams number P 127 Queen b1
basically plays like some kind of
isolated pawn position here in 92 93
probably g6 is the best no to stop
Knight f5 but he plays an idea six I'll
play Knight a5 why not
okay now I'm feeling like there's
something wrong with this position so
what is wrong with this position let's
see can I just take can I just take on
g7 and take on e4 No so if I take on e4
right away we wait night reset is on
kingi 797 King g7 Bishop f6 takes takes
Bishop c6 and somehow is magically
holding magically magically wow that's
incredibly lucky for Andrew but I'll
just retreat the knight now actually now
a forty six five ninety five so it's not
smooth working on all this take on f6
this is not going to end wall
all right so I can check in tape to 7 I
think 94 94 was make some sense just to
get rid of one of his bishops I think I
think it makes a lot of sense clean
clean eh it was probably also just
winning but at least it swimming to get
rid of one of those bishops let's click
clean off five try to play something
special now takes play like rook up d1
try to checkmate him
um
Bishop c6 maybe just 96 alright yeah
just 96 ml to spawn and c4 is going to
fall
you can go c3 but I just take he just
down down two pawns down and this is
pretty pretty bleak although he does
have f6 since I did slightly I did put I
did put my piece on slightly the wrong
squares here so he's going to get some
kind of counter play here that probably
he shouldn't be getting but objectively
that still should be winning
okay h4 he takes always played g4 now
trust seven something prophylactic would
make sense or like teenage - I'll play
g5 to play play for g6 obviously at some
point but now I think this GX is very
strong
clucks c7l 284
three six seven I'm just going to bring
the king closer Thank You shy turtle for
second donation I believe on the screen
d5 like King III
the 51 but now I've chopped and Keaney
897 can create rookie now that's not
going to get it done either on okay
9 2 3 Bishop b4 I'll castle maybe he'll
play e4 Knight 903 so we're going to
play the same same one again I think
probably let's say take takes Bishop g5
h6
mostly c5 again b3 I'll play 96 this
slide will play G 5 94 just take just
play on actually I'm just played this
time how I let him get better than he
should have but whatever it's still
probably I mean my wife's slightly
better it's nothing nothing too crazy
I'll play ok c8 let's see because we
want to take e-66 not take play each 5
try and do something over here on the
kingside h4 hopefully g4 why not just
keep on attacking I don't know so you
can call us really attack but it's
something to do probably will play f3
and then I'll now I'll play like Bishop
age 5 or I'll just play h3 right now
so I keep hearing from people that their
stuff going on at the Chuck's house
again for like the 20th night in a row
over over I mean here in st. Louis so I
might be getting close to stopping you
guys and sounds like all the all the
other players are over at the Chop House
right now to the Chavez Club so I don't
know if I'm going to stop I'm getting
pretty close to that point now so we'll
see so f3 um play something like Queen
h7 maybe or maybe I just King g7
although here allowed this is kind of
weird this like we're playing some kind
of weird like we're playing like the
same position kind of but with plate
everything's okay clean off seven so he
doesn't take I've rookie Brooksie too so
he's gonna have to take but basically
we're playing like the same position
everything's like kind of weirdly
symmetrical here even with the open King
so is it going to take or not he is
thinking a lot
so thank you don't stop thanks for the
donation okay Andrew come on man we've
got to be faster
so it's probably going to be a draw
again but let's see okay now I got
another pondo Andrews kind of made a
mess of this though this weekend I love
this one oh that was bad oh oh he's
getting too tired now
yeah that was just bad alright that's
that's probably going to be enough I
think just just getting too tired of
wandering now you know you know I'll be
I'll play three more in the whole stuff
but that should be good enough so now I
was just terrible ninety four point two
two of f5 I'll probably play 8592
King f1 just keep lying
oh um this take stinks
so we want to do here 92 kingi 127 put a
3 or f3 maybe I think I'll play Knight
f4 I like I like putting a night here
maybe for some extracts see it I'll play
with D 1 9 7 now I think I can play off
3 Thank You penguin for the donation
their ship C 5 that's probably a good
move
mostly bishops C 1 protect just over
protect everything probably for like g3
or King g1 next move just to see oh yo
you can just take
probably g5g three this doesn't look so
so exciting but it's still probably okay
I mean it's not not really not really
what I wanted but we'll see
okay two three takes takes I mean I have
this would be two company that's the one
thing I do have here I am going to get a
check on you one and Bishop b2
so let's let's see what he wants to do
here
it's Queen b6 now I can play work to one
maybe play B for two - whoa King eh eh
well what if can you Jade and then
asleep b4 here or now he's worked off
for maybe I should play B for first
maybe I played the wrong order
I don't know what this is
so now I can take or I can check check D
for Bishop III no that's wrong zhenia c5
s just takes right away looks right
there c5 here can't I just take and play
Queen B - Chuck and I've rook takes d4
and workout for kini one this looks like
me
[Music]
Thank You men striker for the donation
clean us six
I can probably my work anywhere I'll
just go to d2 so it's just simple he
should just resign here I assume so
let's see okay play Bishop f4 is going
to play c4
it's going to play Bishop f4 so I'm
going to read this line okay so c3 I
think I've Queen D fixer
or was I supposed to not really supposed
to take first I probably supposed to
take first but not a big deal if I take
so I can actually take on b2 if I want
here do I want to take yeah why not
let's hit greedy as the saying goes
greed for lack of a better word is a
good thing as Michael Douglas would say
so it worked b1 hopefully I can take
can I take no then or p3 so okay Bishop
e7
so we should be five now I might take
now I think I yeah now I will take the
pawn on c5 with my queens he doesn't
have any correction our Castle might be
three clean III for example
probably he'll take on if you take on d5
I'll take with the night obviously cuz
I've got Forks on c3 so 95 I think I can
say you can probably play a six and this
is Bishop just trapped is there should
be two I guess and like there should be
two Queen takes a 291 Queen eight five
looks winning I don't know I'm going to
get my Queen trap but I don't see a good
reason not to go for this so let's see
let's see how this works out I have I do
tended I have know some in a bit of a
clean sock mood tonight
so 85 I can just take now a beaut okay
one queen bee to just looks winning d6
is a move now I can play work d8 or
pushin Bishop DHS looks good enough to
me
so my blind I went to the naked eye at
leaves but VHS looks plenty or wait
actually maybe not because now you can
take on f6 and play d7 it plays Queen c2
but now I can just retreat I think okay
and just go back to a7 or k1 Queen VHS
looks winning
and okay so we play the e-force now he's
clearly just time to start pretending
that you have stuff here sown is
complete Bishop d7 b5 I'll play rook c8
a tune I'll put it to five okay so you
just resigned so um okay how many more
to play on play what 1715 to you guys I
play three more and leave it at that
I don't know why plaintiff lining on
this is just a bad order I share just
castle but I mean whatever okay Bishop
d6 what is Bishop d6 okay
c5 I can play Kings you wanna I think
Bishop b5 is pretty strong her thanks to
I think someone just donated right or
not no they don't
so I'm just hosted me I guess alright so
there should be five let's see what you
want to do here
there's something like Knight f6 just
fe4
taking five 906 kpop e45 takes on the
594 as an idea I'm just going to go can
be one get out of the way of any any
tricks or so 1983 I'll play ah but now
here does he doesn't an idea you want to
play d4 so I will click Queen d2 if d4
it
I maybe I'll just take just give back
all the material then if I take it's not
not not quite so great so take takes
Queen D for Queen g5 is problem so I
think here I will play come play Knight
f4 just try to get a try to get
something here on e6 and play the Queen
e7 I can go Knight d5
so let's see what you want to do
maybe I mean because FB for I've got 96
so any any capture I've got 96 being
said okay so he sure is going to gambit
everything basically is what he's saying
this will take I'm in one can never have
too much material so I'll play Rocky one
you can take on g2 I guess but I can
take III and play Bishop c6 and it looks
like I'm okay I think I'm okay at least
um excuse me
Queen takes e3 mm-hmm that looks that
was not that was not good that was not
good Andrew
whoo he wants to play on Chuck
I mean keenya trade I can I mean even I
even work up one it's fine but I see no
reason not to just take just play simple
moves
cool guy says cool guy just wrote
something what are you just say cool guy
says stop playing and go enjoy your
youth at the party at the party I'll
head over to the shots house at some
point probably in the next like half
hour so if I'm still filling wake enough
on but we'll see we'll see
for those who don't know the chess house
is the place it's the house right right
on next to chess club I'm just down the
block where usually usually after
tournaments on most toddlers go over
there and and play play some games all
right so let's see so all pretty
standard so far this takes Bishop g7
bishop somewhere probably d3 maybe a Cal
point ABC 722 castles 48 works eh c4
pile or c4 right away maybe yeah I think
that's out for right away is a little
bit dubious here because he takes I can
even just take you for maybe I could is
taking me for right away actually but
I'll just clear Brook CA I mean who
doesn't like a good old fashioned Benoni
and thank you shy turtle for third
donation submission III I can play
Knight h5 I can also maybe play b5 but I
think 95 is the most dramatic move here
just just takes and then play for b5 I'm
also threatening to take on d5 because
this 10
so let's do an Anders games I mean
please clean up - I mean I can play b5
here I also just move my knight I think
I'll just move my knight here just get
out of the way of any nonsense I mean
maybe I just flatten the chance to e5 f5
but it still should be relatively okay
here I'll play e4 probably takes takes
okay I just hang something here I did if
take 694 55 we know 7mm so now I'm going
to really fight to get back in the game
so well maybe not even get back in the
game maybe it's still completely okay
but I just completely blunder that yeah
7 King 896 is a try or just d6 d6 I'll
play rook c6 now it's running maybe to
take b2 also rook c8 was also possible
maybe Brooks it was a little bit better
in fact but let's see what he wants to
do here so please rookie you want so I
can get greedy and grab but it feels it
doesn't feel right I think 95 is the
right move here
Queen d5 now I can play Queen b6
but again I think rook b6 is the right
move just to try one this b2 pond
okay so I'm going to call the bluff and
take pawn he has to show me where the
maid is now because he has if he had the
maid or something then then he's golden
but if he doesn't which it would appear
he does not then um there should be
something to do here I think I'll just
play h6 just know Knight g5
no no 96 non so it's just just you know
just avoid anything of that sort so
Knight c5 that's a good move um c1 once
D 7 or something
you play C 3 D 7 o g7 alright C 3 d 7r c
7r c 5 RP 5 I don't see it so I'm just
going to go for oh he is 96 oops oops
oops oops that could be a problem we may
have a problem Houston
and they have a big problem in fact
what am i doing I don't even understand
what I'm doing right now
yeah I don't I didn't understand what I
just did but come on our that slip there
too but whatever yeah that was that was
just terrible completely fine I just
slipped that up but anyway okay that was
just bad all right last three last three
and then I'm not I'm just done for the
night
I'm flying for too long starting to miss
things everywhere now before try to play
a minority attack over here it's Queen
b3 I could have played a for Houston
that's a good one
that c4 I'll play play rock a c1
b5 play a 592
I mean I'm slightly worse again but this
looks this looks kind of okay it's not I
mean not not perfect not perfect again
not not what I would like to have but
still position okay so he's trying to
attack her on the Kings side
tics I'll probably play like Queen a
three or something or queen bee - maybe
it doesn't have a threat over here does
he now okay's trying to create some sort
of attack over here I need to move
faster to them being very slow someone
as well which is not helping matters
Queen d7 trying to try to flip Bishop g4
so I'll just duck that also just over
protect with all my piece product with
the e3 pawn sir no sacks which would be
three okay now I'm just going to sack
and Queen b6 play g4 g4 h 3 is my plan I
could have taken e6 maybe maybe I could
have taken but I don't really see the
need for it it's also a little bit too
violent
I'm going to go eh three and I mean
since his plants are not great these
pawns on these squares like okay so he
wants to come up with some facility like
Queen ch2 stuff um so I just need to
figure out how best to counter that I
think this is probably the best way just
bring the night around 2 c1 d3 or
something so just yeah bring the Knight
to e2 probably g1 f3 is my plan 91 out
of 350 H to isolate B to our vision g3 I
play rugby - and the Knight f3 I don't
know maybe he'll play rook d7 Knight f3
looks good I mean it's kind of got these
pieces a little bit stuck in stuck in
the corner here
b7 I think I can just point out of three
here yeah why not I don't see takes g3
okay so what exactly is going on here so
I play work f2 is rookie three or
something or is h2 or something I'm in
issue can you two looks fine
so please rookie three so I go clean up
five and now we're after clean
I think I'll throw in a shock okay how
do one this now now this a pawn should
rule today this would just be winning
now
so I played this crop for those in
please c4 okay
still pretty standard though
between two all click we need 75 next
move
all right shy turtle thanks for another
$1 donation so see three I'm going to
play Knight h5 try to put an item off
for maybe take on D for them at the
right moment if it's there if it's there
which it probably won't be but I don't
flip this page six I don't know what I'm
doing but I'm just just trying to make
moves that make some sense a Knight f4 I
like were ke and I think let's click
King AJ just get out of the way of
anything over here I might play off
sticks next move maybe just to just to
over protect the thief I pawn 93 what's
he threatening anything no I don't see
it almost like Queen d8 and Queen e8
probably maybe he'll take on off for
maybe not not sure so
before I'm going to play like Queenie 8
I think I think I'm going to try to do
something along this long diagonal here
I don't know if I have anything right
away but you know something along this
diagonal because e4 is also possibly
weakness
and I also might have f5 coming to like
f5 might be a very serious move so he
takes I can take with the error no I
have to take with off pawn queens before
but what does Queens four actually do
don't do a whole lot but I don't see
anything so I'm just going to go back to
d8 just protect this pawn here there's
your G 3 now I think you blundered upon
Dhin yeah I think now I can just take h3
Knight f4 and I guess he has Bishop age
4 but I can play Knight f6 or not I
think I can I don't see why I can't 93
and now now I just play like Queen d7
and I'm just up a clean pond so this
should be it should be pretty routine
again so King G 1 maybe 94 yeah why not
let's let's try and made him make him
quickly 95 okay first I can take
why not rook F or well somehow this
isn't so simple again I've managed to
bungle this maybe b5 just try to get get
this Queen out of out of c4 okay and
play Knight f6
although I've kind of allowed this speak
on a problem to now but we'll see
okay 95 I will play h6 or not to h6 I
will not play it so the tape now I will
play h6
f96 I take with the Queen so probably
this ago Knight f3 and now 0.05 Queen e2
that's not perfect okay Queen d7 mission
p3 I like g5 now I think four point
seven six five
probably night-night f1 bishop c8
click four again I've kind of miss
played this you know God I'm not not
being very precise in these positions
and hanging you for for no reason as
well it's not going to get the job done
okay
wait don't I have something like Bishop
e3 or rookie three like rookie three up
you three right yeah rookie three fe3
Queen a one is just Chuck made unless
I'm missing something obvious which I
don't think I am
no I'm not missing anything ft3 Queen
and one Queen up one Bishop takes c3
okay so Queen d1 sort of threat I don't
see it's right I'll play we're okay
three oh man it's cancer plus two now
not plus there anymore
Wow oh wow
Oh terrible yes I'll take try to create
something Aramis not not very attractive
to say the least
mm down upon but maybe if I can break
the structure somehow maybe like a three
because now he's going to end up with
these bad pawns so like here I'm going
to take it's going to take the pawn and
now I can castle and maybe get it if I
can get a night to s like never get a
night to to f5 then I'm in great shape
so going to be 60 I'm trying to get this
night around - III maybe attack this
pawn bishop see sighs that is a problem
that is a big problem
um the King h1 clear of t2 I'm going to
try to play for some swindles here maybe
Bishop c5 be for it's still it's still
not simple for block I'm trying to take
on c4 too
95 ah what to do mr. d1 is a move I mean
not the best move but it's a move
do I have anything else like I don't
really see it so I'm going to do it and
he is 93 obviously I'm going to take a
gamble here these probably not going to
play it first okay it's going to play it
so for first Gamble's that he won't play
it seconds that I might get some some
threats here though although actually it
does be too hanging
it was hanging but he missed it so maybe
I don't know this is terras terrible
position for me but maybe I can get
lucky
he had queen bee - and probably the game
was just over but he didn't play it so
maybe there's some hoax I mean there's
the night of five if I can ever get a
night to f5 so take rookie three night
of five now I really want to just take
and play 97 but didn't quite work so
rookie 528 6p8 I guess
well I've Knight f6 out I can just
create can't I always clean off tuna or
something or wiki rookie one what is
Ricky one can't I take and play Bishop
d5 what what why I somehow did I really
suck out that was pretty bad thought was
pretty bad
hey Ivan clean up too is just winning I
mean one of the many wins but yeah this
wow
maybe queen bee ate this queen bee is
somehow maybe hold I mean it's one of
the last tries but I am Not sure so I
have queen g6
this is option one so so you have to go
to new trade so I'm going to grab all
those pawns first okay so let's just so
I grapple or actually I can just Chuck
yeah I can just come back and take the
height and his pawns just aren't aren't
good at all yeah that was not not good
but all right
conditioned us 6 I'll take three bishop
sighs probably Queen B 3 takes c6 pretty
standard position I don't know maybe
I'll play a 5 or a Slovak c8 here -
something efore Bishop g4 x3 all this
take the 96 this should be 2 I'm going
to how to how to play this um don't play
Queen b6 a4 I'll play a six playoff 5
just maybe play for off for here I never
get this move in and then so because
basically I've must this pawn structure
so I think work C sub makes hums takes
three maybe Queenie four maybe not yeah
I think we need for makes okay now Queen
d2 I've got ninety four vs Queen c3
which I slightly must so I'll put Queen
g6 b5 I can take Argan play nights
before right away I think I should
probably play 94 right away
I don't know tough call tough call yeah
I'll play 94 right away
so let's see if it's clean off three so
what you want he wants 12 queenie one
track maybe maybe I do but I don't
really see the point I'm just gonna play
G six we have 14 g7 just try to sit on
the position a little bit here with
everything a 5 make sure the pawns are
not on light squares anymore so this
Bishop can't attack them I'm going ip2 I
do
but $96.00 play Knight d6 which would be
3 tonight f7 I just need to remit over
my Knight Queen 3 now 498 so I can go
ninety six ninety four and just won this
d4 pawn in play h5 I suppose or Queen e8
I didn't see cleaning it that's a little
bit unfortunate
okay Queen so I'm just going to start
Rima nuvaring my pieces everywhere now
played g5 next move maybe get this last
what you know no more pawns on on light
squares possibly actually takes I could
take with the and now I'm gonna go 98
yeah I forgot about that one that's a
slight problem - um 97 g6 kind of got
myself into a bad position here in a bad
way but I still have drawing chances I
think um let's see cleaning three I'll
go 28
oh I logged Queenie a Chuck or while he
had it anyway guess King threw seven
Queens here three but now I can go c5
and now all bets are off so queen three
I can take I think I should take on d4
Queen b3 I'm going to play Quincy six
about 795 3.94 five well about what do I
have a 96 and can I just take our play
d3 meeting
if I check and plate d2
this is not just winning takes excuse me
everyone
sorry about that could be five King a
one table okay yeah sorry about that
everybody okay so this would be 2 3 9 f
3 C 4 C 4 X which would be 3 click Queen
c2 castles Queen 702 92 over payee 1
take pics play 92 93 if you take I'll
just take try to play for Knight f5
again the square is always extremely
important okay I'm turning 95 now is 94
pause well I'll play work d1
play in 92 now truck really try to get
rid of this knight on e4 any way I can
so let's see what he wants to do now
we knew six well exchange I don't know
if it's the best way to play but it
feels like the simplest way you could
keep the game alive of 61 thank you
strike for the $1 donation d1 I'm going
to try to put pressure now 91 93 these
pawns are a little bit loose here so
probably he'll take on b3 I would assume
it's 95 I can play a 4
I don't have allergies but thank you
thank you for the suggestion just just
sneezing but soul Tegel right this is
how you become a GM skip parties and
plate shots I do agree with that that
definitely is one way to become good at
chess it's not the only way but it is
one of the ways it's an IP sighs so you
want to play c3 or something I don't
really know what he's trying to do here
so you take take take nine if one yeah I
don't really like this so much so a4 is
it move the a43 bishop in fact i don't
know why are you so much time to play a
four of course my original thought and
then for some reason I didn't like and I
changed
so let's say okay so 96 maybe 97
interesting that's not what I would play
a take take 50 for fake if takes I'll
probably check 92 night of 3 I don't see
it
since this night always can come to f1 I
think I'm doing quite well here g5 96 is
possible I mean g5 9 h v g5 I can also
just take the night probably
like a knight c6 not here I think I can
grab I think I'm going to start going
going going going for ponds because the
knight does blocks enough one and so
Bishop d6 so now I'll play play g4 I'll
give them this age to pawn if you really
want it th 729 th for real I'm angling
for Knight a5 now on 85 now if I play h3
as you clean with 93 or something cause
you have g5 or I'm not going following
what I'm doing so I'm just play King
tree to a night of 593 put the idea of
Knight h5 King g6 now if I take let's
run a couple packs
what is he threatening nothing right so
I'm just going to wait
I think you just chucked me to hear kind
of so now for yeah I just Chuck mater
okay let's say so what's going to do
this time d4 Knight f6 so swing Knight G
2 this time H for this I believe is
wrong for Roy queenie five okay three oh
no fine IP d7
all right so let's say okay so 93 so he
want to do something sometimes the Queen
before v5 I'll play b5 obviously to
prevent any tricks basically I don't
want I want to keep them in a state of
uncertainty here over how he's going to
develop this piece because takes would
help them develop you're taking castle
okay so he does play a five so now I'm
going to put b5 if you take I'll take
back with the night probably but I'm not
sure
if he doesn't take I don't I don't
really know what is what the purpley so
someone sit so he does take I'll tape
again and now I'm threatening to takes
off of nights before which is looming
okay so Queen c2 and please see for if I
want play Knight c4 also I get no nice
before I can't play so you had Neos play
on there just a good old fashioned like
Bishop d7 makes sons why not just
something simple b3 oh shoot now you can
force add Roger I really just wonder
that that's not going to get it done um
okay what do i do bish gray for a night
if maybe I'll try to make it interesting
why not since the since this is likely
lasting that I'm going to play all I'll
try to make it interesting for everybody
rather than take the draw here
so okay 638 I need to go work before
should be to a play what will I play
here 94 or push page 6 also in oh that
allows Bishop c3 though ah
bad move okay so I'm gonna have to play
for swindles again beside rook e8 maybe
I mean probably this is okay but I don't
think I should win this probably if he's
going to lose something here in the
center that I'm kind of okay but
yeah I know probably this is completely
fine for block what I mean there should
not be not be anything approaching a
winning position so if I play Roque for
work before 93 so I just retreat my
knight he's going to play it rookie
eight if I take he's going to play work
ei okay because would be five that's
five makes the most sense here
let's see if I can sum I mean probably
this is just terrible for me but maybe
there's some hope for 3 I'll play work a
1 I guess now for interesting ok ok -
see - maybe for now step to start
waiting
5450 1406
sexy how this is this has gotten ugly
although did you just must make a
blunder I can take trip g400 throw on a
check and play rookie files I think I'll
clear up D - okay - maybe
way down on time too
yeah yeah that's terrible
oh I was ridiculous that was really
stupid
all right let's gain I have three 2275
take
oh that was really ridiculous I'll
asking but whatever all right
um just kinda play good game this one
it's ridiculous
for those of you who are wondering
actually the ratio is nothing to stamina
it's just the fact that when you play
more and more games at some point you're
you're not going to be able to win ten
to one every time it says nothing to a
stamina so that's sorry Stafford but the
ER was at Stafford was it someone else I
don't know who said that but that's uh
that's not the case
sorry that's nothing to a stand it's
just a fact when you play something over
and over at some point you're not going
to win like five hunting to keep winning
every single game that's just a simple
reality
okay if I play Queenie for he's just
going to take obviously so I could take
I guess I mean if I take and then don't
really want to but I could take and play
like almost saying yeah I think I will
click Queenie for in just to take up
line i th to
oh I guess I might have a problem you
please g3g 3c4 though
so g3 I can also just take probably with
my king we're to 594 looks okay
the bishop d8 I take a 595 looks
reasonable right a 595 F 595 looks fine
so we should see seven maybe I'll work a
one now he he does want to go at five
now so what about this one my king so
okay one off five is no or gage 105 is
no good so C 4 is no good I just like
King drew 1 or something came to one
Queen b6 probably I don't work you
hopefully King off one
so that f5 I can just take each sex
Queen b6 smell point ninety three to
five and I could spring my teen closer
to the center we now for I could take I
guess I don't really want to but fine
I'll just take I'll plan on game on
suity eyes play for six the pawns c5-b
three
tonight six four try to play against
these pawns mmm that was a bad move also
I think 45 should be one now
yeah sure should be winning okay
all right so should I play f5 now so 906
fish bait for think g5 this sauna to 394
through age five if Bishop d3 l just
takes a trim playoff five
I think they can just castle here if I
remember this line correctly which I
could I mean I could very easily be
remembering this whole line but as far
as I recall this whole line is supposed
to be relatively okay for black
you
q1 um G for me
so let's see if it takes 92 Queen h4
looks good cakes you can Castle I guess
and that's really weird
okay so 92 clinch for clinch for looks
like a move
okay so let's see so there should be
four um yeah it's not good so now three
three hopefully Queen g5
I mean takes h4 is probably okay but
this is not this is not I mean I just
blundered this little fish takes me for
I just forgot about it being a move so
HD for maybe I'll play age for there now
why not displayed for Bishop before
queen g4 so let's so Bishop about for
Queen g4 94 maybe 94 e5 looks reasonable
so he does take okay so I play e5 here's
95 95 Queen up five though it looks like
it's reasonable yeah what am I missing
I'm sure surely I'm missing something
here but I'm not seeing it ah he is f3
first okay so f3 hopefully queen g6
Bishop HP but now I can take on any
foreigners pawn structure is really
really ugly in fact I mean he has big
problem service now if you take that
Knight g4 in fact Knight g4 is coming no
matter what he does so he is his real
problem since 94
and this is actually pretty pretty ugly
for one I mean his bishop is so bad here
our work h1 I might even be able to play
work f2 I am just ignore completely but
you know I don't I don't see it so I'm
just going to take and take and take and
play like work to for play like c6 or
now I'll add disrupter that was bad okay
so c5 take should be winning out this
four plus three still it is okay good
okay so
all right so wait it's not a free piece
hmm so evidently it's not about sandwich
just I mean I think both players or both
is getting a little bit tired now so and
it's getting a bit late so this I mean
this this this will be the last game I'm
going to say that right now and this is
going to be last game so I have three
night of six for hopefully 94 castles
53:5 probably castles what was take h3
um what is the age three is he want he
wants play chief or or something and I
can take this is kind of weird but okay
I'll just keep playing normal I'm gonna
ignore all this weird stuff that he's
doing over here and just keep on playing
normal normal is like 92 I'll take in
player qi6
d5 I was in 95 which is very important
his 94 is that his plan if I play e5 c5
is interesting I don't know if it's good
but it's interesting but is it the right
way to play here and I don't think it is
I think 95 is the right way to play
there should be 2 and I can play e5 I
can play queen up to 6 also I don't know
what the right move is here but I'm
gonna try to clean off 6 just try and
grab some material it's 94 then I'll
take on defy everything yeah I know I'm
just going to grab up on let's see what
what's you singing hazard after I've 93
I also after I don't have to move right
I might add that too so we'll see
let's ago so Bishop f3 does he have a
threat
I don't see an actual threat so I'm
gonna go go shop c4 hit this work here
on e 1 let's play work e8 or poof nah
just log page 5 but fortunately he
missed it thankfully that would have
been a disaster okay I'll play Knight g5
Bishop h5 I'm going to play Knight h3
discover Chuck Bishop c6 that's a move
to now if I take a ch3 King h1 Queen h4
you got the trip sheet 3 F should I go
for it or not night h3 King f1 King f1
Queen h4 Bishop g3 rook to e3 fg3 Queen
g3f gh3 move tough decisions ok I'm
going to go for it I don't know if this
works or not but it makes son so he's
going to play Bishop g3 I'm gonna take
I think rookie for ISM of rookie 494 is
the question 94 he has to take he has to
take right yes 94 looks right and I
think this should be checkmate I mean
what's I'm missing something here but I
mean I think this should be checked made
especially for I just tape Queen 4
what's he doing I just take no the Sri 8
queen of three but this should just be
winning
so yeah all right you guys so I think I
was three hours in have slot law two
games a lot of games so um yeah alright
you guys so I think I think I'm going to
stop for now and that was quite quite
quite a few games so I hope you guys
enjoyed the stream enjoyed the game so I
I'm sure I'll be back soon but for now
I'll probably go over it's a chess house
maybe play against LaVon and Sergey and
all the other guys play Blitzen bug
house so I will catch with you guys soon
so have a good evening everyone Hut and
have a great weekend
all right adios